e talked about this a little bit yesterday, but
I want to dig into it more because the story is
growing. Donald Trump is threatening and now
promising to potentially humiliate himself by
releasing his upcoming 60 Minutes interview early.
And he seems to be sort of like a runaway train
that at this point, nobody can get under control.
Yesterday, I explained that Donald Trump on
Tuesday filmed a 60 Minutes interview for for this
Sunday. He was interviewed by correspondent Lesley
Stahl. We learned moments after it all happened
that Donald Trump ended the interview early. He
abruptly left and he didn't come back. And then he
almost immediately tweeted a six second video of
Leslie Stahl at the White House without her mask
on, which is really weird behavior for a president
who's supposed to be an adult. Well, then Trump
threatened to release the 60 Minutes interview
before it would air on 60 Minutes as if it would
be some kind of punishment to them. Tweeting,
quote, I am pleased to inform you that for the
sake of accuracy and reporting, I am considering
posting my interview with Leslie Stahl of 60
Minutes prior to airtime. This will be done
so that everybody can get a glimpse of what a fake
and biased interview is all about. Everyone should
compare this terrible electoral intrusion with
the recent interviews of sleepy Joe Biden. Now,
it didn't make any sense then. It still doesn't.
But since then, it's gotten even funnier with
Donald Trump tweeting pictures of himself sitting
for the interview, I guess meant to make him look
strong. But then hilariously, he tweeted out
pictures of his press secretary, Kaley McEnany,
handing Leslie Stall a book of Donald
Trump's accomplishments on health care.
And it's one of these obvious props. It's like a
gigantic oversize book with thousands of pages.
But when you zoom off the pages, they look like
they're blank, like it's not even just a prop.
In theory, where it's just filled with,
like executive orders and random stuff.
It actually seems to be merely a prop with
blank pages of no with no content whatsoever.
And Trump thinks that that makes him look good
enough that he's tweeting it out and drawing
attention to it. Well, it's even worse than that
best. Levin wrote a great article in Vanity Fair
which explains that Donald Trump
spent the entire afternoon on Tuesday
after the interview brainstorming a with aides how
to go after Leslie stall. It's not exactly clear
what he came up with. But by Wednesday morning,
Donald Trump's chief of staff, Mark Meadows,
was on Fox Business Network complaining
about Leslie Stall. Take a look at this.
Well, he didn't walk out. I mean, the
characterization of that. He spent over
forty five minutes with Leslie Stahl. I've looked
at every single minute of the interview and then
some we have tape of every single minute.
Listen, when you have a 60 Minutes report,
they should be a reporter, not an
opinion journalist. And she came
across more like an opinion journalist than a
real reporter. Journalism should have standards
and we need to get to the bottom. So I
think the American people be able to see it.
Sort of strange to hear a Trump administration
official talking about standards not being adhered
to. But Donald Trump really may be on the verge
of a self humiliation here. He again today talked
about how he is planning to release. I guess they
must have their own recording of the interview
to prove something. And by the time you
even listen to this clip or watch this clip,
it's theoretically possible that Trump may have
already done that. Now, on the back end of this,
some of the people who saw the interview who
have spoken to Vanity Fair said, you know, the
truth is the interview is not that bad. It's not
like it's the interview. It's OK. It's not great
because it's Trump, but it's at least not worse
than the things Donald Trump has been saying daily
at his rallies. So this may be another one of
these instances where Donald Trump is calling
attention to something that would not have been as
big of a deal if Trump had let it go. But this has
been a theme of the presidency, self-inflicted
damage. A huge part of the entire Russia fiasco
was Trump's self-inflicted damage through tweeting
and other unnecessary things. And you could even
mean, I don't know. But even what led to Trump's
impeachment, which was the Ukraine fiasco,
some aspects relate to optional things,
Trump said and things Trump tweeted and
things that Donald Trump did, which at least
circumstantially might not have created an
environment in which Donald Trump ends up getting
impeached. Maybe not, maybe so. But the point is
the self-inflicted damage is never ending, truly
never ending with this guy. And that's another
aspect of, you know, the final debate is tonight.
And for those who hear this after the debate,
you already know the outcome, of course, but be.
I mean, the Barack Obama Joe Biden rally yesterday
during which Trump started tweeting conspiracy
theories about Barack Obama from bright baat
with the 60 Minutes stuff that's
going on with Donald Trump's recent
sort of I don't I don't know if I want to call it
desperation. He's not despondent, but he seems to,
at least in the back of his mind, recognize
that there is a chance that he gets completely
embarrassed in 12 days or however long we have
left until the election. It seems to me that
Trump is on a hair trigger to completely
self-destruct. And as you know, tonight,
during four of the 15 minute section, during four
minutes from each 15 minutes section of debate,
candidates will be muted while their opponent
gets their two minutes to speak uninterrupted.
I would not be shocked if Trump just can't control
himself and tries to shout over the muting and
gets picked up by Joe Biden's microphone or
by moderator Christine Walker's microphone.
Anything could happen tonight. I invite
you to join me tonight. We will be live
about 30 to 45 minutes before the start of
the debate on YouTube, Twitch and Facebook.
The debate is at 9:00 p.m. Eastern. I
will start 30 to 45 minutes before that.